baby's been kicking this whole video um
it's super cute though because i'm like
trying to focus so i'm like okay baby
hold on hold on
[Music]
oh let me hemp it
so for this video i wanted to talk about
my pregnancy diet because a lot of you
guys have been wanting to see more
pregnancy content a lot of you guys have
actually asked what is it that i eat
day to day throughout this pregnancy
and i really appreciate by the way that
you guys are curious and that you want
to know more about this pregnancy
because personally i'm like oh people
probably don't want to hear about this
let's just keep pregnancy stuff to a
minimum but you guys have been so eager
to come along on this journey with us
which i so appreciate because you know
we love you guys like family but before
we get into this i want to give a shout
out to chat books for sponsoring today's
video
i made a beautiful photo album for our
wedding so
the previous one that i had if you guys
have been following us for a long time i
had another one a long time ago but that
one actually gave to mama chan because
she loved it so much so i was like oh my
gosh we don't have a wedding album of
our own and luckily chat books came
through so i created this beautiful
hardcover 10 by 10 photo book of our
wedding and i ended up adding a whole
bunch of other photos that i didn't have
in the previous album
i am absolutely obsessed with this
because the photos came out so beautiful
and so clear and
it was so easy to do this too by the way
you just go on the app i uploaded all my
favorite photos and they make it so easy
to actually edit and rearrange layouts
you could even make collages
it literally takes out all the hard work
from scrapbooking you don't have to
worry about any of that you just go on
your phone easily add all the photos you
want and create a beautiful book and
it's pretty cool because you can add
custom colors you can create different
kind of covers and you can add captions
to all of your photos too which i
decided not to do but they do have that
as an option which is really cool and
they make it so easy too you can connect
your facebook or instagram account like
any of your social media and you can
just directly get photos from your
socials to your album super easy chat
books is the modern way to get photos
out of your phone and straight into your
hands and super affordable prices start
at 15 for a 30 page book plus free
shipping so you can click the link in
the description and download the chat
books app and get 20 off with your first
chat books order when you use code
holiday 20 or you can just scan the qr
code on screen right here so get your
holiday shopping early this year a photo
album is a great gift i know i will
definitely be making more especially for
mama and papa chan because they love
photos and i honestly love this album so
much i have it on our coffee table and
i'm so looking forward to making more
with the baby
what's the babies here so let's get into
the pregnancy and side note all these
years with isaac being in the public eye
and you know me being a mother no one
has ever
ever given their two cents about how i
parent isaac but it's funny how now
there's just a lot of opinions on what
it is that i'm doing right or wrong with
this baby who's not even born yet
because like i know when i vlogged um
going to malibu with the girls that was
like the one and only time i really
decided to get a whole bunch of mexican
snacks and they were not the healthiest
of course it was amusing to me and also
endearing that you guys care so much
being like you shouldn't be eating that
it's not good for the baby which i
really appreciate because you're caring
but don't worry i i know what's good and
what isn't good for baby and i do
everything in moderation if it is gonna
be like crazy sugar or whatever i've had
a kid
for all these years and not once has
anyone ever said like you're doing that
wrong or you do that whatever but now
all of a sudden uh with this unborn
child that's coming this way which is
okay it comes with the the platform i
guess so yeah a lot of you guys have
been asking what i've been eating
throughout this pregnancy and i know
that there's some of you out there that
are also pregnant this is a really great
question because i'm also very curious
what you guys are eating in terms of
other pregnant mamas out there when it
comes to food i've always been kind of
completely lost but throughout this
pregnancy i've discovered my appetite
and discovered a sort of love for food
so it's been really fun um just
exploring different things really
learning about like how certain foods
can be really healthy and i'm just
learning to stay away from other foods
that aren't so good for me and baby so
yeah i thought it would be really nice
to just go into what it is that i eat
throughout one day so for breakfast i
usually make myself an oatmeal
and i jam-packed this oatmeal with all
kinds of goodies i've been grocery
shopping a lot and been getting a lot of
fruit so i usually put in like
blueberries and raspberries but
sometimes we run out so i'll end up just
doing like bananas and like some sort of
nuts usually almonds is what i put in
there
and i just make it really really hearty
and i top it off with a spoonful of
peanut butter which oh my god i
i don't know how i never thought of this
before because i absolutely love peanut
butter and i always eat an oatmeal but
maybe like about a year ago uh someone
suggested to put peanut butter in my
oatmeal and i'm like oh my god mind
blown this is amazing and now i cannot
have my bowl of oatmeal without peanut
butter cause ah it's so good i love
having peanut butter in it because first
of all i love that creaminess but also
there's a lot of protein packed in it so
it's really healthy for the baby yeah
i'm just like trying to find out ways
where i can
incorporate more
like protein or more like whole grains
or whatever it is that can be good for
baby which is a huge difference from
when i was pregnant at 17 with isaac
because
when i was pregnant back then i had
absolutely
no money i was at the whim of isaac's
dad's
mom because she would be feeding me
other than that like it was just nothing
but junk food i also was really
uneducated in terms of what was healthy
and what wasn't and you know growing up
mexican
a lot of our cuisine isn't really all
that healthy like there's a lot of like
fats involved a lot of um just carbs
like carb heavy and so whatever i would
eat with isaac would just be purely junk
honestly a lot of meals were del taco
like a lot like the del taco quesadilla
was all i ate with isaac and it's just
really interesting to see how
crazy of an impact that had
in isaac's appetite and and the way he
views food where now with this baby i'm
like okay wait now i know better i'm
more educated when it comes to healthy
foods i actually would make an effort to
make myself eat every two hours but i
was not thinking at all what i was
putting into my body it was just like
okay i just need to eat because i need
to feed this baby i would have like
sugary cereals for breakfast i don't
know like cinnamon toast crunch or
captain crunch and that would be my my
breakfast i almost never saw a fruit i
think throughout isaac's pregnancy like
i never really consumed any vegetables
like i'm telling you it was bad like i
i don't even know how this kid came out
alive like it was crazy so after
breakfast i'll get in a snack and it's
usually almond butter toast like even
though i've been raving about peanut
butter but when it comes to this um
after breakfast snack i like to consume
almond butter why i don't know is it
healthier i think so
[Music]
honestly the way i started eating this
is because of casey casey brought it
home one day he was like oh we gotta try
this honestly that's where i get all my
food info is from my husband because he
absolutely loves food and he like dives
deep in a lot of food like nutrients and
history and all that he loves it so
that's where i'm getting my information
from that's why i'm kind of like i kind
of know but not really uh but yeah so he
brought home almond butter and i've just
been eating that with some whole wheat
bread yeah it's just really delicious i
like to toast my bread before spreading
it and i pair it with a glass of milk
because during pregnancy they say you
know milk is really great it has a lot
of protein all that stuff all that good
stuff so for lunch i have been making
these meal delivery kits that have been
coming in
and the reason why i subscribed to to
them is because i
am a complete noob to the kitchen but
now
because i know food is so important and
for the betterment of my health and the
baby's health i wanted to learn how to
start cooking and so i decided to do
these like meal delivery kits as a good
way to get my feet wet in the kitchen
and so for lunch i've been making a lot
of these meals but i just recently
canceled my subscription because i
finally gained enough confidence
to believe in myself
to go out
shopping for myself and make myself
a meal or make the family a meal based
off of what i've learned
through these delivery kits so um that's
coming up soon i'm really nervous
because this is my last week with these
kits
and so we're gonna see what i can come
up with but what i've been doing so far
throughout this pregnancy for lunch is
making these meal delivery kits so
they're super healthy lots of color on
the plate lots of vegetables
uh low carbs um
and it's just been really fun to really
understand how food works and like how
it cooks and like different types of
food too because i've been i've been
exploring with like different vegetables
and i've never eaten like fennel and
squash and all this other stuff where
i'm like what i've never incorporated
these these foods in my diet before
another reason why i really wanted to
learn how to start cooking is because i
realized like you know isaac is 13 about
to be 14 and i feel really guilty i kind
of failed him in this one aspect of his
childhood which is to have a mom in the
kitchen and to not like to have like
home-cooked meals made by his mother
because luckily we've had casey in our
lives that has has filled in that gap
but
i just feel like wait hold on like this
is something i always wish i could grow
up with like having
you know a mom in the kitchen for every
meal home-cooked meal and that's
something that i had always wanted and
so i had always wanted to give this to
isaac but i never like really went for
it i was i don't know what it was it was
just insecurities i guess or laziness
whatever it was um i just i had never
taken the steps to be that mom for him
but now that i am able to be that kind
of mom
i'm just really striving for that and
not not just for isaac but also for this
baby that's coming into the world i want
them to know a mom in the kitchen so
then after lunch i'll start getting
hungry again and i'll head down to the
kitchen for another snack and sometimes
it'll be an avocado i'll just crack open
an avocado sprinkle a tiny bit of salt
spoon it up and enjoy it or i'll reach
over to the fruit basket i'll get a pear
or a clementine or a banana
or recently i found these really cute
tiny little crab apples which are
just apples but like mini forms oh my
god they're so freaking cute and yeah
like i'll just i'll go for some fruit
yeah and when i was pregnant with isaac
very rarely did i ever actually consume
fruits it was mainly like
like processed things i remember
drinking kool-aid a lot when i was
pregnant like what
that's so unhealthy i'm honestly
surprised that i did not get gestational
diabetes with isaac but man i was 17
like my body was meant to have kids now
at this age this 31 year old body i
definitely have to be very careful yeah
for those of you that want to know like
a good way to set yourself up for
snacking throughout the day
i have these amazing nibble trays and
so casey and i we took this health class
recently for this pregnancy and during
that health class there was this
suggestion for nibble trays which is
like these like containers with multiple
slots in them that you can just put a
whole bunch of different foods in and
it's funny because in this class they
were really suggesting this more for
like toddlers like a toddler nibble tray
but casey was like oh my god i'm gonna
make you some of those so you can have
some throughout your pregnancy and so
whenever you're you're hungry you could
just grab one of these like trays and
then just nibble on whatever you want so
that's another thing that i've been
snacking on a lot recently
and i'll be putting in all kinds of food
i even got some goldfish like little
crackers i put in there some dried
cranberries grapes blueberries
raspberries strawberries like all the
berries
i put them in these nibble trays i also
bought some like crackers and stuff that
occasionally i put in there or nuts like
walnuts cashews
macadamia nuts i'll just put all kinds
of different things in these nibble
trays and i'll prepare them all in the
beginning of the week or whenever i run
out of them and just snack on them
throughout the day just making sure i
always have something in my belly and
then for dinner a typical dinner that
has been like my favorite dinner
throughout this pregnancy is
casey's salmon he makes his amazing
baked salmon he tops it off with a whole
bunch of ginger
and like soy sauce and it just so it's
so delicious and we pair that with some
rice and a type of veggie sometimes it's
brussels sprouts sometimes it's spinach
sometimes it's asparagus yeah that's
definitely been my favorite and salmon
is super healthy it's packed with a
whole bunch of protein a lot of good
omega-3 oils and all that good stuff and
so that's been
something that i've been trying to
consume more of is like fish but in
particular salmon protein protein
protein like it's crazy because when i
go visit my midwife like um she'll ask
me like oh have you been experiencing
any headaches or any leg cramps or any
of that
and sometimes i'll be like oh yeah i
actually have been getting a little bit
of headaches and she's like oh you need
up your protein that's why that salmon
dinner is like my ultimate favorite
these days and after dinner of course i
still get hungry so i end up topping off
my day
with a
like after dinner snack and a lot of the
times these days that snack is a
quesadilla
and recently i switched over to whole
wheat tortillas because it's just
healthier like whole wheat is just
better casey is usually the one that's
making me the quesadillas late at night
which i really appreciate he he brings
over a quesadilla or it'll be another
almond butter toast
or a lot of the times we'll whenever we
have mango in the house he'll like chop
up some mango put some lime and we just
go to town on the mango so
yeah that's pretty much an entire day's
um meals for me i try to really just
keep it whole foods keep it fresh keep
it full of protein full of good fats um
complex carbs try my best
and
yeah honestly i've it's a huge
difference from this pregnancy
to the last i have had some
a little bit of like a thyroid scare
issue sort of thing my thyroid levels
earlier on in the pregnancy were kind of
high
so i got referred to an endocrinologist
so throughout all these maybe like about
three months i've been getting monitored
nothing's been crazy my thyroid's still
working properly the levels were just
like on the little borderline area where
they were like wait we gotta keep an eye
on this
um but other than that
pregnancy's been going great uh super
happy
um it's just been feeling like
harder and harder to breathe in case you
haven't noticed this whole video i'm
like
i feel so out of breath
a lot of the times but yeah i think
that's about it you guys that's my whole
day
with eating i'm still gonna come out
with that video of like really comparing
isaac's pregnancy with this pregnancy i
guess i'm just waiting until i'm a
little bit further along to really get
like the full scope of the whole
pregnancy so
look out for that video and thanks for
watching
see you guys
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you